we have our complete sliders to change
the mood okay that within or the context
within which what you're saying is going
to and then I use that with that to get
that okay that looks very
[Music]
funky okay this is real time voice to
image a beautiful
garden a beautiful garden with a
terrible
Dragon it's very rainy right
now the dragon is
angry it has lost one of its most
precious
possessions a small egg where is it
where is the egg it's
hidden the dragon is looking around for
the
egg unable to find it
finally there's an
idea it was in the cupboard all along
the dragon is very very
[Music]
happy excellent very neat what do you
chain here like what's the model behind
this so it's it's based on it's using
stable diffusion 2.1 but we had to redo
the pipeline because we wanted to be
able to compos it over and over on a
evolving Panorama yeah so uh there's a
long technical description give you of
how we do that so it's a specialized
model that way we're doing voice
recognition on the laptop sending it
there yeah uh we have a bunch of ways to
tune and shape the experience like I
have them let's see what can I do here
let's uh you know we can just uh amp up
the
Picasso see if it will do it oh you know
I haven't I haven't that's it's I hav't
what it says here now it'll
be yeah yeah no one's cled there before
uh I think it's cuz I haven't this isn't
synced anyway so you you put up stuff up
and down and it will it will adjust we
have a complete sliders to change the
mood okay that within or the context
within which what you're saying is going
to affect the background are you
modulating The Prompt there or are you
modulating some sort of it's adding to
the prompt okay so it's adding
you know very finely weighted editions
yeah very cool does it work with
different languages no it does not which
is a problem I have a lot of
international students that I teach and
uh that's one of the first questions I
get asked so you could do voice
recognition in different language You'
still be stuck with the fact that the um
that the model was trained on English
captions and doing this so you'd still
have to do a translation somewhere of
course we can do a translation but it's
still you know it's not the same as some
sort of multi many many language caption
relationship so it's unfortunately
restricted English right
now colonialism sneaks in in so many
places with these Technologies we have
to be on our Lookout all the time for
that is it okay if I record a bit I'm
doing some reporting is it pornographic
movie except everyone has clothes on and
just talks about science but it is it
super amazing
for yeah go on what the story behind the
comics I'm an artist so it's kind of
what I already did before so these are
just recordings of my days okay you know
some stuff I do in my life yeah it goes
on for years and years and years okay
all the Absurd or small things that just
pop up and then you make comics out of
them I typically I would make a normal
comic out of that but now I'm also
making these AI things out of them okay
so kind of giving it to the tool the
tool is on the poster there what what do
you what do you use for a tool so it's a
of stable diffusion yeah these guys down
there made if you go
there like why does it speak to you
because to use a tool like this what
what does it allow you to Dole yeah it
makes meigle okay but not
always but do you find it to be a source
of creativity do you find it to be a
source of expression what it exists we
might as well use it in positive funny
ways before we use it in a way that
makes us cry yeah so it's inventing new
ways to work with technology we don't
quite really get that it makes something
really interesting and funky and you're
just like why not it's there try do you
have an example where you can really say
look this is something I would not have
done before without the tool like do you
have a particular example that you like
this for example so so this little gu
mushrooms into
pancakes they made from this so that's
the original drawing what's for dinner
potato mushrooms you know how to make
potato mushrooms by the way no okay so
you get a potato you get a machine that
makes spirals do you know what I mean at
the end from the potato you will have a
mushroom you have to try it to sh okay
okay okay maybe I can nonetheless try to
find an example for you the perfect
potato mushroom maker okay from there
obviously I would have just left it
there or maybe I would have made a comic
but not the same thing yeah what I'm
talking about is this oh okay these are
made from different veggies yeah I see
and I planted them in the forest but
it's funny and that's the machine that's
left so neat yeah of course I would have
done something eh but I would never in
the million years have made that okay so
this this can also be seen like as
animation so so yeah you can look at
that like
you wouldn't make that you know unless
you're brain
damage so this this uh it takes the
image and you add a prompt you add a bit
of text of how you want to change it
yourself or you ask the tool for image
and text there different options MH so
one of the options is you can ask it
what you think that is and it's only
animals on the beach okay almost absurd
enough for me to be interested in yeah
and then I used that with that to get
that okay that looks very funky I'm well
my cat's been sh shrimp ified and the
house is a
mouse and there are actual Surfers on
the beach it could become like a Doctor
Seuss
book my cat's been shrimp ified and the
house is because of this is hilarious
that's why I use it good very exciting
and now I'm kind of doing a project
called being moose where I am moose and
I'm using this to transform myself and
you are I am already there don't worry
about it very good I'm doing pretty okay
on that and these are these are still
drawings drawings and okay very nice
very cool so yeah you could also take a
picture of that if you ever interested
you are my last person but you know what
you're the last person from leaving so
you can take that if you want story
of.com okay excellent that would make an
amazing pornographic movie
wow at the science conference fantastic
has the place to BU is if you want to
make this kind of movies like where did
you make yours at the science science
conference machine learning conf yes
that's the place that's the place wow
you're going to get so many
customers you should uh you should go to
the people they you know they have these
posters they should all put their only
fans on the post put posters there no
yeah
let Che it out all right I'll leave
these with you because I have no need
for a paper but I have everything on
record very good thank you very much for
the the rest yeah
thanks